a una escalada de las tensas relaciones
entre Estados Unidos y Rusia podría
conducir el incidente entre un avión de
combate su-27 ruso contra un dron reaper
mq9 estadounidense que sobrevolaba el
mar Negro en una misión de vigilancia
esta interceptación fue tan peligrosa y
tan descarada que la fuerza aérea de
Estados Unidos se vio obligada a
estrellar su dron en aguas
internacionales es otro acto imprudente
el presidente Putin y su ejército
y quiero decirle al Señor Putin que
detenga este comportamiento antes de que
sea la causa de una escalada
involuntariation el pentágono dijo que
uno de los aviones rusos golpeó la
hélice del dron dejándolo inoperable el
mq9 es capaz de transportar municiones
pero no confirmaron si las llevaba
consigo
debido al daño estuvimos en posición de
tener que chocar en el mar Negro que yo
sepa en este momento Rusia no superado
ese avión Pero nuevamente en términos de
nuestros esfuerzos de recuperación no
tenemos ninguna actualización para
proporcionar en este momento
el Ministerio de defensa de Rusia a
través de Telegram dio parte de lo
sucedido y niega haber atacado el dron
en la mañana del 14 de marzo la fuerza
aérea de Rusia detectó un dron
estadounidense mq9 que volaba en
dirección a la frontera Estatal de la
federación de Rusia sobre el mar Negro
cerca de la Península de crimea debido a
una maniobra brusca alrededor de las
9:30 hora de Moscú el dron mq9 emprendió
un vuelo no guiado con pérdida de
altitud y chocó con la superficie del
agua Este es el primer incidente de este
tipo desde la invasión rusa a Ucrania
hace más de un año
Moscú ha expresado repetidamente su
preocupación por los vuelos de
inteligencia de Estados Unidos cerca de
la Península de crimea